hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
um uh what the [ __ ] i thought it was
march 30th march 29th
jesus christ this month's never going to
end
i'm telling you right now if you every
year you're just like oh my god the year
is flying by i know i've said this a
million times but i i cannot stress
enough how slow the the the
month will go by if you're not partying
at all
if you're straight edge it's j if you're
just sober sober just
slows it down you know
you go from watching full court fast
break basketball
to a pitcher's duel actually a pitcher's
duel takes
kind of goes quicker doesn't it the
strike well unless they're mowing people
down i don't know what it is
all i know is it's taking a long time
all right
and uh i almost almost smoked a cigar
yesterday my wife gave me the green
light
we were hanging out right we are having
a good time and weed is legal
out here man so my wife went into a
store
and bought herself a doobie man and
um she's like isn't your cigar bar
across the street isn't there cigar bar
i was like why yes there is
she goes why don't you meet me over
there so i say okay so i go
in there and i start browsing oh
and i'm smelling the smells right and
there's all these [ __ ] guys
not a lot of guys but there's people in
there smoking cigars and they're cigar
smokers
so they're cool they're not talking
they're just smoking their cigars
just [ __ ] chilling watching a game
right
cigar bars right it's it's where adults
go
until the broads show up and then it
gets [ __ ] and second they show up you
know
it becomes another thing you know unless
they're cool which you know
in fairness to the broads like there's
very few cool guys
and i'm gonna say that i'm a cool guy
the way that all of these white people
are just saying that they're woke
because they said so
okay if you could say you woke then i
could say i'm cool if that's how the
game's played
if i if i am whatever you say that oh
whatever i
say i am i'm gonna do a remix of the the
the
eminem song um so i go in there
and i start browsing right
and then the owner comes in hey i
haven't seen you here in a while i'm
like hey
you know i kind of been laying it off
he's like hey i got a great cigar
for you to come back to and i was like
hey why don't you show me what it is
because i was looking at one of those
little uh one of the nubs there
my favorite little [ __ ] afternoon one
there a little connecticut and up right
she goes i got something for you i got
some this this see this cigar it is a
cigar you want blah blah i'm holding my
hand
smelling it ah it's right there right
[ __ ] pain for the crack right
whatever the heroin i'm tying off my
[ __ ] i'm getting into it and then i'm
just like
you know what no i can't do this i only
got a couple more days i said i was
gonna [ __ ] do it
i'm gonna [ __ ] do it and um
i i just left i just i you know i did i
i got a soda
or a pop if you're from the midwest
and i um i went into uh
and i just he let me sit i've spent
enough [ __ ] money in there he let me
hang and drink a [ __ ] coke
then my wife came over you know what i
mean she took a couple of puffs
yeah we were hanging we just had like
the best day i was driving my old truck
which i just got fixed you know i had a
problem with the uh
um the steering uh power steering or
whatever
the the the the steering assembly
uh it's been leaking forever and sort of
fixed it you know those old [ __ ]
trucks there's always something leaking
but i was driving around and there was a
guy actually my wife instagrammed it
there was this guy in front of us had
like i think a lamborghini
and the license plate said you're weak
which i thought was funny
i mean you know are you really being
arrogant i mean you got a [ __ ]
lamborghini you got to talk a little
[ __ ] right
and then he had like the aluminum foil
wrap on it on the outside where you know
if you stand at this angle it's gold if
you at that angle it's silver
and he's cranking the stereo it's
[ __ ] hilarious he's in like stop and
go traffic just going
one one one
one [ __ ] hilarious
and you know of course i was [ __ ]
laughing just going oh my god
look at me
acknowledge that i'm here right
so i was a couple of cars behind and uh
actually saw this older guy was there he
said you know what i'd rather have that
old truck than the [ __ ] lamborghini
that made me feel good right i was just
we just had a great day then we went out
we got lunch
i had a great day hanging with my wife
um and i didn't [ __ ] up i've kind of
you know i was doing well with the food
i tried to go like plant-based
and i last weekend i made a [ __ ]
chocolate malt and i'm telling you
the food's a drug i i [ __ ] went back
to the crack pipe
and then this week i was just like yeah
you know i lost a good
six pounds and you know what i think i
put them all back on i didn't have the
[ __ ] courage
to back get back on the scale you know
but i did a show last night somebody
took
a picture and i saw my belly was pushing
out you know
you know what the worst thing even the
second you get just a little bit of a
gut
it makes you it makes your pecs look
like man tits
you just can't have your stomach pushing
your t-shirt out
if that's happening then you gotta
upgrade to the button down
and if it's still happening then you got
to get a sweater and it just it never
[ __ ] ends you just got to keep adding
layers
you know so whatever i'm
i'm starting from a better place than i
did the last time
it's just i can't [ __ ] lose weight
unless i'm doing cardio
whatever that guy on youtube you know
cardio burns fat right
no whatever the [ __ ] he's talking about
i don't know maybe i'm an alien but
it works for me it works it works for me
remember bobby and whitney
um i uh
yeah i got to get an elliptical in my
life or something like that or
because even when i just walk up the
hills out here there are plenty of parks
and [ __ ] and do the stairs
it's you just don't burn as much um
calories i don't think unless you're on
like a [ __ ] elliptical because
it's essentially i'm running without
pounding my feet my knees
you know i'm just wearing out my hips so
anyway i just had a [ __ ] awesome
weekend you know i did a couple of
really fun shows i worked three nights
in a row
you know i did a show friday night
at uh supernova is what they call it i
did a
show there and then i did
my um what the hell was the show
i did oh i did my australia new zealand
show i had a [ __ ] great time doing
that
and i got to work with al del benny who
i started off with who
was the funniest i've ever seen him so i
can't imagine how funny he is in front
of an actual like live crowd
because you know there is sort of like
that delay as you're doing it just a
little bit but like he was so goddamn
funny and he had this bit
about uh speaking of hip replacements he
got a hip replacement and they gave him
some pills
and it caused him to fall off the wagon
and it's the best [ __ ]
i've ever seen him do and i've known him
for almost 30 years
and it was uh it was so good we got to
talk
via the zoom thing right before we got
caught up a little bit
i just missed that guy i [ __ ] love
him to death man so if you're down under
and al del benny is performing anywhere
go see that guy
absolutely [ __ ] hilarious he's a good
[ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ] you say down there um
thank you to people new zealand who also
showed up
um it was cool seeing you guys hanging
out in your living rooms and all that
type of [ __ ]
seeing what you were laughing about what
you weren't i will admit towards the end
i thought i was kind of bombing but what
happens is when people are too loud next
to their microphones they start to mute
people
so in the end i thought i was like
bombing but then i got all these texts
saying no man you killed you killed so
i was relieved that it went well and
somebody had a dog that was like
barking or something in the other room
so they couldn't figure out who it was
and they never quite got to him so um
but it wasn't barking nonstop but it was
still
uh it was a lot of fun yeah
so um anyway so my truck's fixed
and you know i had to talk my wife into
writing she bounces around too much i
like
it's like come on man it's the weekend
get to take my [ __ ]
good-looking woman out you know this is
this is what it is
come on let's she's like all right all
right i had a great time you know it was
cool
we pulled up to the restaurant and you
know my truck shifts three on the tree
so i was like you know how to drive like
you know shift on the column he goes i
do but why don't you just back it up
right here
and just he gave me that little thing
you know that little
you know way they don't valet they let
you leave it in front of it that little
extra [ __ ] you know thing
made me feel cool and i got out and of
course i quote goodfellas right
i walk by you know my wife's like
they're gonna let you leave it right
there i said yeah and i looked at her
and i go
it was out of respect
so of course she rolls her eyes oh god
it goes in
she liked it she like she likes that i
gotta [ __ ] i i like to think she did um
anyways isn't that what every toxic
[ __ ] person says isn't that their
catchphrase she liked it
sorry um plowing ahead here
so um and then lastly i finally got
all of these pictures that i had i
finally just got somebody to come over
here
put them up and uh and then put my tv
where it needed to be
so i could get my stereo i bought a
hi-fi man
and my speakers are on either side of
the table underneath the stereo i'm so
[ __ ]
psyched and you know what kills me i've
been waiting to do that for like two
years
not two years because i got the stereo
last year but like
i knew it was [ __ ] up with the second
i got in here and i just for some reason
i just kept thinking oh [ __ ] they're
gonna come in here this is gonna take
forever
these guys were done in like under two
hours
and um i finally you know i got this
cool picture of me and patrice
i got one of me and derosa and then i
got this big space on my wall and i got
a
there's a good photographer out here and
i'm gonna get one
a me versi and bartnik next time we do a
show or whatever smoking cigars or some
[ __ ]
i'm gonna get a cool black and white one
and then i gotta get one of
myself and my wife and then one of me
with the whole family
and then i'm good you know i got my
parents over in the corner it's [ __ ]
the whole thing
came together just had a great weekend
right and just when the weekend couldn't
get oh then
i had another show call them old billy
shows this weekend
i did uh i did a show at the rose bowl
not in the rose bowl we were at the rose
bowl
so we were in the land as my dad says
the lawn
chrysler did you mow the [ __ ] lawn
well why not
well it's just like your studies you're
[ __ ] off
oh christ you're just like your mother
um
we were on like we had like the lawn
like uh
area on on the side where you could
actually see where it says the rose bowl
and it was nice enough that they lit it
up for us
um and you know i hadn't been out there
since the rose bowl
in 2020 january before all this [ __ ]
happened
and uh it was cool to be there
sober after the first time
possibly ever and uh i was backstage and
stuff and there was
uh you know there was some stuff you
know i could have partaked in and i
didn't didn't have any booze didn't have
any
weed you know he can microdose these and
i was just like no no no no you know i
started to feel like i was an airplane
you know when the guy's trying to walk
through the airport and the hari
krishnas and everybody's coming up to
him and he's just throwing them out of
the way
uh it was really fun but uh the people
that sponsored it
was a really i wish i knew the name of
them a really cool uh
weed company or whatever and i guess
they got the best vaporizer ever
out there so i got that from my wife um
but it felt good and they said you want
some you want some weed and i said no i
don't smoke weed it felt
good to say that all of that [ __ ] no i
don't drink
so i think i'm gonna try to do this
again next month now here's the thing i
am not
done forever with booze maybe booze i
don't know
but any of this [ __ ] but like i am done
using it the way i was using it
where i was using it as uh a way to
numb pain it's like all right i need to
figure out what i'm upset about and i
need to [ __ ]
address it with an
unaltered mind figure out what it is
forgive whatever the hell it is i did or
whatever somebody did to me just
and let the [ __ ] go and then come back
strong
and start partying for the right reasons
that's that's what i'm gonna do so
anyway i watch
um i watched uh
you know racing oh let me talk about i
didn't even talk about the the rose bowl
show
so it was like 700 people in case
um and the crowd was [ __ ] amazing
even though you couldn't hear 90
of them fortunately there was some
people with pickup trucks and people who
were sitting outside
and they were laughing they were kind of
down front so i could sort of play off
of them
but uh i am not going to lie to you dude
it was it was uh
you know there were moments where you
know
if i didn't make those two little
pockets of people laughing it just
i felt i was joking i felt like i was in
a sci-fi movie
and i was pleading for my life in front
of this unsympathetic
board of p of whatever they were that i
couldn't quite see
um but it was a real fun show david
spade was out there jeff ross
uh some younger newer younger comics
that i met
uh this one guy a former marine coming
up
his last name was simpson i forget his
first name but uh just met a really lot
of cool people out there
um adam eager was there
uh all of the shores
paulie peter and scott were all there it
was [ __ ] it was great everybody got
you know
tested rapid tested so you could [ __ ]
hang out i still wore the mask you know
so but uh i went up there had a great
time and then i got to bring up one of
my favorite comics of all time ian
edwards
who has an amazing special called ian
talk
and uh it was great had a great [ __ ]
time
great goddamn weekend so just when that
uh couldn't get any better
um moto gp
and f1 racing started this weekend right
and
i woke up i was like oh [ __ ] did i miss
it
you know did i miss him or whatever and
the f1 race i'm not gonna lie to you i
missed the first like 30
something laps so i watched the last
half of the race
um the moto gp i put on during
the moto 2 race so of course i'm looking
for the american there
native of los angeles joe roberts who
was in eighth place when i watched him
finished sixth i believe
and then i watched the uh
the moto gp race which um
you know i didn't realize that uh
actually well
i knew that mark marquez wasn't going to
be in it he had some another difficulty
you know he broke his uh humorous last
year and he had some sort of
complications or something that he's uh
working out
but i noticed i didn't see uh
that's hilarious i'm looking for andre
de vicioso when it comes out andre
davizio so wife comes up first
uh and i wasn't sure if does does this
guy have a ride this year
this year man doubts motogp race return
in 2021 oh he won't be back
like that was my favorite uh rider in in
in the main
main thing there but anyway he'll be
back
um sucks he's not there but i watched
the race
and um maverick vignales wanted
was a great race i missed the very first
lap because the people who were coming
to
switch the [ __ ] around in my office here
came
and i was watching it live for once
first time since it's it's
hasn't been on uh channel 220 on directv
but
uh what was amazing was uh
was it is it johann mir whatever i don't
know what the [ __ ] his name is he was in
second place
last year's championship and he's
hanging on to the very
end and then he took a turn wide right
in the end and there was two ducatis
right behind him
um and they did the old slipstream there
and then it's great the announcers come
to ducati to do cats
[ __ ] screaming their asses off i mean
nothing gets me off the [ __ ] couch
like motogp it's [ __ ] amazing
[ __ ] amazing it was a great race so i
posted about it then everybody goes i
hope you watched that f1 race
looks like max verstappen finally has a
[ __ ] car to uh
compete with uh lewis hamilton so i got
all
excited like oh [ __ ] did max verstappen
beat lewis hamilton right
because lewis hamilton and mercedes are
just so [ __ ] better than everybody
else
i have to fight hating lewis hamilton
because he's so [ __ ] good
i mean i understand they got more money
and [ __ ] so that's annoying
so anyway i'm watching the [ __ ] race
i put it on and i'm like you know
and uh of course lewis hamilton's in the
lead
and i'm watching the race and i'm
watching i'm watching and uh
all of a sudden you know max verstappen
just keeps closing the gap closing the
gap he's behind five point something
seconds four point something sex three
point something seconds he starts
talking about the uh
what do they what do they call that not
the slipstream the uh he's gonna have
the
whatever the [ __ ] they call it begins
with a d
i can't remember anything um because i'm
doing nine million things
obviously uh
so he gets right on his ass and then
lewis hamilton does something that you
never see him do he makes a [ __ ]
mistake
turn 10 he goes wide
and max verstappen is right on his ass
and he's got that [ __ ] whatever the
[ __ ] they call it
and you know like the next place he has
space
he goes to the outside of him and dude i
am jumping
up and down jumping up and down
he [ __ ] blows by him and there's like
[ __ ] two laps left or something three
laps left and i'm freaking out
guys gonna do it it's gonna be greg
racing this year
right screaming and then all of a sudden
he just slows down
and he lets louis pass him
and my jump just slowed down so i was
just bouncing on my toes
what the [ __ ] the [ __ ] just happened
well you know hamilton's
he had no back end he was flying his ass
and was all over the [ __ ] track
max verstappen had get total control of
his car
he went by him and all of a sudden he
just he [ __ ] slows down he lets the
guy go passing what the [ __ ] is going on
and then the announcer's like oh he when
he passed him
he wasn't on the track so he has to let
him go by
and i was just like ugh
and he was still close to him but i just
knew
i just knew i'm like lewis hamilton
does not [ __ ] up twice
ev once every [ __ ] 20 races he will
[ __ ] up
and then when you go by him you cannot
[ __ ] up at all
and if you do [ __ ] up that's it the race
is over
and they were screaming and yelling the
announcers were screaming yelling trying
to get me back
up off the couch but i did not get back
off the couch
because i've been watching since 2015.
okay i'm still new
but i have watched long enough to know
that the race was over and i just was
slowly sat down on the couch
sank into the cushions
and i just sat there expressionless and
of course max verstappen's car because
he got off the track there was something
in his tire all of a sudden he's having
problems
he can't close the gap downdraft
that's what they call it i don't know if
he's going to get clo
he's not going to get close enough the
[ __ ]
race is over and i cannot tell you
how disappointed i was
that uh max verstappen didn't win but
then at the end of the race
i was i was still excited where i was
like listen
okay lewis hamilton is the derek jeter
the tom brady
the bill russell the bobby orr the
michael jordan
of this sport okay so
but all of those people other than
michael jordan because michael just had
no competition but all of those people
needed they like you know joe montana
needed elway bill russell needed will
chamberlain bobby
i don't know if he had any pier but
there was still guys like ken dryden
just amazing goalies and [ __ ]
um tom brady peyton manning that great
duel
you know and in the end whoever's the
best you know a-rod and derek jeter
and nomar was a thing for a while
um and then just at some point the
greatest of all time just
pulls away from all of them so what i'm
hoping is
to get a little brady peyton manning
thing going on here
with lewis hamilton and max verstappen
but it looks like max verstappen has a
great car
and i i was tweeting i really hope this
isn't a fluke
um because f1 is one of the great sports
of all [ __ ] time and
and they just haven't had every sport
goes through it there'll just be a
period that happens where there's just
the competition isn't where it needs to
be um
so i am really excited about uh f1 for
the first time in like two three years
because i've kind of been like
lazily watching it you know i would
watch the start of the rain be like all
right well lewis gotten you know
if he's in first place after the first
turn the [ __ ] race is over so i would
just wait for that race where
he somehow [ __ ] up in the time trial
one should be 20 races
and he was like you know starting from
like the second or third position then
it could be fun
to watch him basically overtake people
eventually so
another thing that i put to bed was i
never understood in the moto
2 race this guy from great britain won
and whenever they win they would play
what i knew
as my country tisothy my country
tears of the sweet land of liberty
of thee i see and i'm like what the [ __ ]
you know why are they playing our song
all right and then i just finally looked
up and i just said my i looked up my
country tis a three
and uh looked up that and i wrote looked
up
england's national anthem and it turns
out we ripped them off
it's their song i did i didn't know that
so ours goes my country tiers of the
sweet land of liberty of the icing
where where am i [ __ ] this song
it's kind of hilarious lyrics it goes
god save our gracious queen
long live a noble queen god save the
queen
now right off the bat you can't tell me
that [ __ ] wasn't looking over the
dude's shoulder as he was writing the
lyrics
yes you gotta mention me in every
[ __ ] line
send her victorious happy and glorious
long to reign over us god save the queen
i mean how [ __ ] [ __ ] whipped at us
are they
long terrain over us they're like just
total [ __ ] cucks to this lady right
then what i like this is this really
interesting lyrics
uh our lord our god arrives scatterer
and the mice just trying to make it
right and make them fall i love this
part here
confound their politics frustrate their
nervous tricks
navy's tricks i don't say that on the uh
hopes we fix god
save us all um and this is this the new
world order one here's the new world
order one part
not in this land alone but be god's
mercies known
from short to shore here we go lord make
the nation see
that men should brothers be and form one
family oh jesus the wide world over or
whatever
yeah okay there you go there you go
there's the illuminati they wrote that
stanza
so that's cool so that's um
that's the national anthem and his
typical yank
i i did i had no [ __ ] idea i've been
watching race racing forever i'm like
are they giving a [ __ ] that the english
guy won that they're [ __ ] playing our
song
you know like that time i saw the
stanford band
play uh the farmers only you don't have
to be
lonely when they were playing iowa at
the rose bowl i thought they were giving
a [ __ ]
so it turns out it's their national
anthem which is called god save the
queen
great [ __ ] tune and it also makes me
appreciate the title of uh
the sex pistol album right
but that angry redheaded bastard right
god saved the queen
right i'm saying it ironically
um it's amazing how angry that guy still
is
is it joni ralton roy my i'm living up
to me name i'm in a rotten mood
always are those flowers i don't like
them
um
that guy makes me look like a [ __ ]
breath of fresh air
um oh jesus now where in the [ __ ] am i
goddamn
i swear to god you close a [ __ ]
window and then everything just goes
away this is
you know what it is because i'm writing
all of this [ __ ] right now
oh are you bill are you a bit what are
you [ __ ] drake
working on the weekend like usual
nobody asked you drake nobody asked you
how often you work and what you're doing
okay i've said it before you work for
yourself if you don't want to work this
weekend then
don't that's that's up to you you're 100
in control
um all right so
anyway so now i'm i'm adding
now that i am i am uh going to try to go
another month
oh jesus another month with nothing but
having
one chocolate malt a week which i can't
even [ __ ] do that because if i eat
that
then i'm just like you know what
i want a steak dinner i want some
something salty
some mashed potatoes or whatever
um
dude you know what's overrated is a
goddamn [ __ ] coaster
a coaster has to have weight to it
because if you [ __ ] put a glass on it
the condensation then makes the glass
stick to the [ __ ] coaster
if the coaster doesn't have any weight
you go to pick it up and then it falls
in the [ __ ] floor
these are the frustrations of the first
world
um yeah so i'm gonna try to add yoga
oh jesus i gotta do it i said i was
going to go sting in my 50s
all right because that [ __ ] guy looks
amazing he looks [ __ ]
amazing sting is still [ __ ]
and he's he's he's almost 70. i mean
look i know he's got
he has zillions of dollars i know he
lives in a castle
right um but still that if he walked
into a [ __ ] bar
he you know without even playing bass if
he wasn't famous that guy could still
[ __ ] he could pull something out of
there
he might have to drag it out of the mud
at this point but he could drag
something out of there
and go home right so
seems to be what he does right he does
yoga and he [ __ ] for like three days
straight i don't know what he does
practices his base in odd time i'm just
gonna do what the [ __ ] he does because i
want to be
in in his shape um
and i'll tell you right now you don't do
that by [ __ ] making a goddamn
chocolate malt every week that just
throws your whole [ __ ] week off
oh i had another one last night oh it's
[ __ ] delicious
[Music]
it's my [ __ ] it's my everything now
it's my crack my heroine
you know at least i split it with my
wife
and i would be lying to you if i didn't
resent her
when i have to pour that one half into
her little thing her little glass
you know i do the whole thing i put the
whipped cream on it i put a little
[ __ ] cherry on top
it's the gayest thing ever and i [ __ ]
love it uh but it does throw my diet off
for the whole [ __ ] week
so anyway i woke up this morning but
dude and i did you know worked out and
then i went for
a nice long walk with my son
um he was in a great mood
i had an awesome time with him with him
this morning i'm starting to think he
might be a drummer
because we have this little metal table
and he always pulls himself
up on it and his little fat handles
little fat baby hands they got fat feet
little fat hands right
and he's just [ __ ] banging on it
right so i'll just play a little rhythm
whatever
and he stops and his eyes get all wide
and he gets psyched
and he's banging again it's so funny he
holds himself so close to it
that it's his palm all the way to his
elbow it's just
whacking down on this thing right um a
little fat arm
so i don't know i'm not gonna force
music on either one of my kids but i'm
definitely
going to expose them to it we will see
uh we'll see what happens but all right
let me let me read a little bit of
advertising here
and then i'll talk to you about uh some
more [ __ ] about driving my truck now
that i got it back
um okay here we go oh jesus what do we
got here how many we got here how many
you got here
couple two three four okay oh these are
all fun ones butcher box
but i need to be eating at night i need
to eat a nice [ __ ] protein
decides to pound my hand and some greens
drink some water and go to bed
no chocolate malts all right put your
box everybody
oh speaking of which i [ __ ] forget not
not [ __ ] butch bucks but
hang on a second with those guys so i
was talking to aldel benny right and i
was talking about trying to be sober and
that type of [ __ ] right
and i talked to him i was making these
chocolate malts and he was laughing
saying whatever works
and i said yeah they're different than
you know the malts were from the midwest
it was different than
you know the east coast that had the
fraps and then he wrote
fribble and i had not thought about this
this place in the east coast called
friendlies
and they had the fribble and he had a
big plastic glass with the red writing
a friendly's fribble and then through
looking that up
i realized that in in rhode island they
have something called an awful awful
this is what the internet does to you
right so now i'm going down a
a malt frap tribble awful awful
rabbit hole enjoying every second of it
so the awful lawful
started i think in new jersey
and it was their version where they they
don't use uh
what is it i i don't know what the [ __ ]
it they use like frozen milk or
something like that there's something
different that gives it a different
texture
so they gave it to some [ __ ] guy back
then to try it out
and he said it's what do you think he
said it's awful big and it's awful good
or something like that so they started
calling it the awful awful which is
really a terrible name for something so
delicious
but evidently there's some sort of
creamery or some [ __ ] in rhode island
well they make one and now guess what
this is what i have to do
you know what's funny i remember reading
about ac dc
and when everybody in the beginning used
to see angus young doing all that [ __ ]
bouncing up and down like a [ __ ]
lunatic
the whole show everybody thought like
how many how much
drugs is that guy on and he wasn't on
any drugs he was stoned
sober and his [ __ ] was he after the show
he smoked cigarettes and he drank a
chocolate shake
all right and if you ever watched angus
play guitar how much he moves and how
[ __ ] skinny he still is
and the fact that he's five foot nothing
and the fat has nowhere to go you know a
tall person it's easy for them easier
for them to be skinnier they got places
to hide the fat right
this guy's got nowhere to put it he's
still thin as a rail and it makes me
think back to that guy going like cardio
burns fat right
no well [ __ ] talk to angus young man
all right sorry so that's on my list
when this whole pandemic ends when it
[ __ ] ends
when we have the hatfields and mccoys of
the [ __ ] vaccinated and the
non-vaccinated
you know i keep saying to people who
don't want to get the vaccine i go so
back in the day when they cured polio
you wouldn't have got that [ __ ]
vaccine
you just would have walked around with
one leg bigger than the other one
and they're like well no that's back
when they did it right what do you mean
back when they did it right
they were doing just as much [ __ ] up
[ __ ] they were doing more [ __ ] up [ __ ]
back then
where the civil rights movement was
there's all kinds of
the [ __ ] cars you drove you hit a
tree the whole [ __ ] engine and
steering wheel went into your chest
you squirted out the side like
toothpaste
but you know people have i like i only
give [ __ ] to white people i don't give
[ __ ] to black people because
the government did give them syphilis i
don't know why i'm laughing i'm just
saying you know
i we do not condone giving of syphilis
to people of color on this podcast all
right and with that let's get to the
advertising
um i can't get to the advertising
because i keep i still have too much to
talk about another thing
you know why i like to another driver i
love max for stepping
uh but sebastian vettel i love that guy
because he has a temper
and he clearly this guy passed him in
the race and he clearly just smashed
into the back of him and then he
immediately goes
he goes why'd he leave his line
[Music]
[Laughter]
i think he gets mad when people pass him
and then he [ __ ] drives into him and
then he throws his hands up like what
happened
i don't know what happened you know and
then you got kimi raikkonen who's just
above it all
driving like a [ __ ] maniac in in some
car that that's not worthy of having him
um anyway i'm just psyched that
i'm just psyched that uh you know max
verstappen
hopefully will have a car that can
compete with lewis hamilton it's gonna
be fun
all right anyways here let's here we go
now here's the advertising butcher box
everybody
all right talk about what you're
planning for spring cleaning etc
rearranging redecorating rooms throwing
out junk organizing the
the kitchen of the office so i believe i
already talked about it um you know i
have a bunch of knickknacks that people
gave me that uh
i'm going to be giving out to people at
shows
um just because i have like a lot of
clutter here and
i appreciate it everybody that gave me
that stuff and i held on to it for years
and i would think about the shows and
everything but i'm i'm drowning in it so
i have to
you know pass it on to other people
um the same way i'm getting rid of some
of my letterman suits and conan
o'brien's suit [ __ ] that i wore from way
back in the day
uh i gotta figure out a cool way to give
those to somebody who gives a [ __ ] um
or maybe i'll donate them to the comedy
and magic club because they have a
basically they have a ridiculous museum
of uh
all kinds of stand-up stuff like a
smithsonian level deal
with that um so anyway yeah i'm doing
that [ __ ]
um anyway you might not love cleaning
but you can
something but you can't help the feeling
can't help feeling great about taking
care of your space no absolutely
i i i i used to come into my office and
i get depressed because everything was
just [ __ ] all over the place
and now it's the i can see clearly now
the [ __ ] is gone um
anyway and taking care of what goes on
in your plate is just as important jesus
am i learning that the hard way or what
butcher box helps you make
meal time moments feel special year
round each month
they send a box of the highest quality
meat for a better price
than in the grocery store giving you
more time to spend cooking and sharing
delicious high quality meals
with family and friends my favorite cut
is i don't know you know usually i'm
loving the
the heritage uh breed pork but
i think um i don't know i'm kind of into
the organic
chicken or maybe the steak i kind of
been craving steak lately
anyway it's the best meal shipped right
to my door which means one less trip to
the grocers option
options like 100 grass fed and finished
beef
free range organic chicken my favorite
heritage breed pork
and wild caught alaskan salmon you don't
know what they're gonna do
and sugar slash nitrate free bacon mmm
bacon it's the way meat should be
butcher bucks is the most affordable and
convenient way to get healthy humanely
raised meat
with butcher bucks you get the highest
quality meat
around uh meet around for just six
dollars a meal
and they even have free shipping
nationwide except alaska and hawaii
um all right right now butcherbox is
offering my new
offering new members ground beef for
life
that's two pounds of ground beef in
every box for for the life of their
subscription
that's free food people and for all
monday morning podcast listeners
butcher box is offering ten dollars off
their first box
that's two pounds of ground beef for
life
uh for uh for free for life free for
for the life of the subscription uh plus
ten dollars off your first box just go
to butcherbox.com
burr that's butcherbox.com
capitalb-u-r-r
all right candid uh unhappy with your
smile
you don't have to be you know thousands
of people
have used candid the clear comfortable
removable and practically
invisible aligners to help straighten
their teeth and
now they love their smile
it's like losing weight for your teeth
you know what i mean if you're a [ __ ]
mushy tub of [ __ ] like i am right now
you're not taking your shirt off down
the pool
you know but you straighten yourself out
you got that shirt off you're stretching
you're giving people directions slowly
pointing
showing off your guns right
we ever think that you know your lips
are the shirt for your teeth
and how long you've been covering them
up or maybe bringing your hand up
because whenever you smile people hear
the theme to austin powers but
they
baby right you know what you don't hear
people thinking about mike myers when
you're smiling right listen to these
listen to these testimonials
cameron s cameron s newton
no cameron s nashville tennessee
you know once once i started candid my
life completely changed
i started going to the gym more i
started eating better
i even have better dental hygiene my
goal for my wedding was perfect teeth
and candy got me there
and candid is here to help straighten
your teeth so you can fall in love with
your smile too and if you fall in love
with who knows maybe somebody else will
too
your treatment is prescribed and closely
monitored remotely
by a licensed orthodontist who's an
expert in tooth
movement you'll have the same quality of
care you'll get from an
in-office orthodontist from the comfort
and convenience of your own home i mean
jesus christ
when you really think about what they're
doing for you okay how much they
they're they're literally if you have
straight [ __ ] teeth
your number goes up if you're a four now
you're a five maybe a six
drop a few pounds with butcher bucks
look at them tying them all together
and while other companies use general
dentists candid only works with
orthodontists these are specialists for
your teeth
with candid the same orthodontist who
created your plan
is with you from start to finish so you
never have to wonder how you're doing
the average candid treatment is just six
is just six months uh you'll start
stealing seeing results way before then
and it costs
thousands less than traditional braces
become your best
you start straightening your teeth today
right now you can save 75 dollars
on candid starter kit go to candid co
charlie oscar candidco.com and use the
code bird that's candidco.com
code bur take advantage of this limited
time offer
to save 75 dollars on your starter kit
candidco.com code bur b-u-r-r
you know what's hilarious is i actually
you know the other side is if you have
crooked teeth i think you have a lot
less chance of being attacked by a
gorilla
because when people go to the zoo and
they smile when you show your teeth to a
gorilla that means
you know you want to take his [ __ ]
bananas or some [ __ ] i don't really know
so you got to keep covered up so if you
actually have crooked teeth the only
advantage of crooked teeth
is you will not get beat up by a gorilla
at the zoo but other than that
other than that you're going to be
walking around dragged down by your
teeth being looked at as a three or a
four
when you could be a strong six or a
seven depending on how far you take the
gym thing
you know all right me undies everybody
do me undies me undies fix your crooked
teeth
me undies be undies then cover that
[ __ ] beef
with some nice soft panties or maybe
underwears
you might be transitioning i don't cares
get this [ __ ] and pay for it and use my
code so i make money
so i can keep fixing my truck all right
no skid marks on these all right me
undies everybody my undies believes that
comfort is about more than what's
touching your skin
it's about feeling comfortable in your
skin that's why my undies
sources the softest most comfortable
fabrics imaginable
express yourself
every day in new limited edition prints
because
what you wear on the outside should
empower you from the inside
that's like their whole thing man you
know when you rush home to change into
something more comfortable
that's me undies it's like they pull the
clouds from the sky
and spin it into undies oh my god that's
amazing
uh undies socks bralettes i don't know
what that is and
loungewear wouldn't you like to sit in
the clouds
in the comfort of your own home you know
you can choose from undies styles in
sizes extra small
to 4xl everything from
from [ __ ] wrestling all the way up to
andre the giant
the sustainably soft micro modal
modal and new ultra light breathe
fabrics
are so comfy and well breathable so you
can move freely
that's right your junk and sachet in the
comfort of a [ __ ]
cumulus cloud um or not
it's up to you meundies has a great
offer for my listeners for any
first-time purchasers you can get 15
percent off and free shipping
myani's also has their problem-free
philosophy
if you're not satisfied with any product
for any reason they'll refund it or
exchange it gross
exchanging underwear disgusting no
caveats no questions
does me undies sell like [ __ ] new or
used underwear like they do down at the
bmw [ __ ] dealership
pre-leased pre-owned um to get your 15
off your first order and free shipping
go to meundies.com
b-u-r-r that's meundies.com
oh and look who it is last stepping out
of the shadows everybody it's my bookie
how the [ __ ] you doing you look good how
everything go with the family all right
get the [ __ ] out of here
all right whether you're a basketball
fan or a fan of sports in general
everyone knows that march is the time
for college ball to shine
and with my bookie there is no shortage
of opportunities to cash in
all right and for the ncaa tournament so
far it's been a wild ride
the number one and number two seeds have
both been knocked off
what michigan lost
gonzaga lost the [ __ ] are you talking
about
hang on a second i was so busy
michigan basketball wait a second
this can't be right this can't be right
no they're playing right now they're up
14-8 over the seminals jesus christ my
bookie
you're freaking me the [ __ ] out
the number one or two seeds what in one
region all right anyway
okay let's get back on the trap here the
number one seed have been knocked off i
mean
what top seed hasn't been sent packing
the dogs are barking
uh but if college ball isn't your jam
and take a swing at the mlb
lock of the season with a bet you simply
cannot lose
uh myb has lowered um oh my bookie
has lowered the over under on total runs
to
0.5 for the opening day matchup between
the dodgers and rockies
so smash that over and grab your free
money people
talk about who you're betting on to win
march madness who's in your bracket i
got the michigan wolverines i went all
in
all in here comes the river sign up
today mybookie.ag
and use promo code burr burr to secure
your first deposit bonus up to one
thousand dollars
that's mybookie.com with promo code bird
to claim your free
cash bonus and add even more excitement
to sports
to the sports you love bet anything
anywhere anytime with my bookie hey
you what are you doing all right get the
[ __ ] out of here all right
let's do the questions here for the week
for the week
for the brit british lady listener
responding to male brit listener
hey bill cheerio um i'm a longtime
lady listener and you are keeping me
company in my kitchen office as i work
from home through this pandemic that's
great
oh i'm scottish
the [ __ ] podcast i'm i can't do a
scottish accent um i'm scottish but i
live in wales
um i live in i lived in london for 15
years
jesus christ i get around before moving
here so my husband and i could actually
afford to buy a house
i'm responding to the male brit who
emailed you about the proposed curfew
for men
which was suggested after a young woman
was snatched from the street and
murdered by a serving
london police officer wow
see that america is an american story
right there happening in london
american piece of [ __ ] in a lot see it's
not it's not always us
all right the background to this is
before the cops had worked it
worked out it was one of their own
officers
before the cops had worked it out wait
before the cops had worked out it was
one of their own officers who had
kidnapped and murdered this girl this is
so [ __ ] horrible
the met london police had advised that
all women should stay at home to avoid
the same thing happening to them
the female member of parliament who
suggested the male curfew
oh because a guy did it to the woman
that's so [ __ ] stupid what do you
think the [ __ ] serial killer is going
to be like well i guess i'll
i guess i got to stay home i guess i got
to start following rules now
baroness jones did so in protest and to
provoke a response she later said i'm
just trying to highlight the fact that
when the police
victim blame by asking women to stay at
home
we don't react but when i suggest it for
men everyone is up in arms
they're not victim blaming they're
trying to [ __ ] protect you
because this is what this person is
going after
i swear to god dude i swear to god
the only thing that's important right
now in life is that scientists said
by 2050 the amount of plastic in the
ocean
is going to outweigh the amount of fish
i just watched this [ __ ] thing
where these fish are up at the top of
the surface because there's no oxygen in
the water and these whales have to
create a new way of hunting
because of all the plastic we're
throwing in there and everybody's going
like right damn [ __ ] victim play that
victim trying to save your [ __ ] life
you know if the cops could say hey can
all psychopath
women killing serial killers all stay
home this evening
then you could go out
victim blame jesus [ __ ] christ the
world has gone [ __ ] nuts
if somebody was out there killing
redheads and the cops told me to stay
home i wouldn't be like
stop freckle blaming i would [ __ ]
stay home
or maybe you know start working with the
cops and walk down the street with a
revealing outfit and try to lure the guy
out of the bushes
wearing my little wire on my brassiere
uh the listener who told you about
the suggested curve for you sounds like
a little like my husband who responded
by saying not all men do that
and a curfew for men criminalizes the
good guys i wholeheartedly agree that
not even
close to all men behave or act like that
but almost all women
have been affected by male violence
at some point in their life uh you know
and we've been all been affected by
toxic women and psycho chicks too
okay human beings are unbelievably
flawed having said all this if the cops
told me to stay home because there's
some piece of [ __ ] out there kidnapping
and [ __ ] uh
you know killing women i i would stay
home
because i get their thing where it's
kind of like all right well this guy has
this hungary needs to feed he's going to
go out
he's got to go up uh he's going to go
out
no wait boy the cops didn't tell the
guys i know i'm all confused
the lady said for the guys to stay home
i don't give a [ __ ] this is what i would
do
if i was a man or a woman whatever the
cops are telling me to do
they're trying to catch the [ __ ] guy
so i'd listen to the cops and i'd stop
making it about yourself
male or female all right anyway to give
you an idea just a few things that have
happened to me are
i was severely beaten up in the street
by an ex-boyfriend
i took that [ __ ] to court and he was
convicted almost 20 years later i still
have nerve damage in my face from it
jesus christ on a morning commute to
work i was struck in the nose
in nose-to-tail london traffic
they suited and booted douchebag
and the mercedes next to me was wanking
whilst looking me dead in the eye
i sat with my hand on the horn shouting
out the window and pointing until he put
his shaky
skanky dick away jesus
christ what the [ __ ] is going on in
london
i was horribly and intimately groped by
a man
on the london tube i was filming in
belgium oh jesus at least you [ __ ]
finally left london
i work in t uh tv production and some
[ __ ] member of the public came out
of nowhere and broke my tit before
running away
i was wrapped up in a winter coat so
wasn't wearing anything that caused me
to
quote ask for it this is horrible
i'm stating the obvious most recently i
was followed home in the dark by some
angry
crackhead guy as he was so messed up on
whatever [ __ ] he taken i could
i could thankfully run faster than him
and got into my house before he reached
my street and worked out where i lived
every single female friend i have has
similar to worse stories than mine
worse stories than nerve damage 20 years
later
every single female friend you have so
whilst they agree that not all men
behave like this instead of pissing and
moaning it would be helpful for guys
if guys got his angry when the
authorities suggested us women should
stay at home to avoid being raped and
murdered
on a lighter note we're looking forward
to when you're going to be back over
yeah i think both sexes need to just
listen to the cop
because i think you said it there the
authorities are trying to make sure you
don't get raped and murdered
that just let the cops do their work
everybody get out of their own ego and
start making this [ __ ] hat fields and
mccoys
there's a bunch of great women and men
out there that would like to see this
guy get caught and the people whose job
it is to get him caught
are the cops so if they come up with the
game plan why don't you go with it
it's like when the doctors come up with
a game plan to beat a virus why don't
you go with it instead of trying to
become your own [ __ ]
doctor but whatever what do i know i'm
just a [ __ ] comedian all right
plowing ahead here
um all right men's curfew another one
hello rusty bill hello rusty bill
just addressing the email you received
regarding a men's curfew the suggestion
was tongue-in-cheek oh i didn't realize
that the narrative is women must not
travel alone but
out at night after a certain time dress
appropriately etc
to be safe so in response women are
saying they are not the ones who should
be
changing their behavior as it's men who
are more likely to be the cause of
violent crime against
both genders uh that is okay the idea is
so astoundingly [ __ ] stupid because
you're talking about someone
who would rape murder and kidnap
somebody as if they
are a rational
human being as if the only reason
that they're doing this they they're
trying to
increase the odds of you not getting
picked that's all they're doing
while they go after this guy and try and
find him that's all the [ __ ] they're
trying to do they're trying to catch
this guy
and everybody's like well how come you
don't do that i give up i give up with
all of that [ __ ]
all right millennials what's up you old
gen x ginger balls
now what's up old gen x ginger balls um
i've heard you talk a few times recently
about enjoying these young crowds and
how they're not getting offended as
millennials
millennials do figure i'd let you know
that these young people
at your show most likely are millennials
no they're not and i know the ages of
millennials so don't even start the
youngest millennials are 25.
so unless you're performing to a bunch
of 21 and 24 year olds
you've got us i say us 27
no no this was a super young [ __ ]
crowd
i understand you guys are also all the
way up to almost 40 years old i'm the
one who's been saying how old [ __ ]
millennials
are don't [ __ ] preach this back to me
okay i'm telling you there's been a
shift and i'll give credit
to maybe the ass end of millennials but
that front end of millennials are
[ __ ] horrific
[ __ ] horrific and i i
performed in front of enough of them but
i understand that you're a millennial so
you have to defend
your generation which is why you called
me gen x even though
i don't identify gen x because gen x is
somehow tied into grunge
and grunge took all my music all my
[ __ ] metal music off of the
mtv back when they played music the
countdown
all right an ex-muslim problem
no jesus hello bill hello bill hello
newman um i watched every stand-up
you've done
you've had online and been a long time
fan well thank you although i didn't pay
attention to the podcast
till you took mushrooms
okay i'm a kurdish man born in musi iraq
i hope i said that right
i grow up i grew up during the the war
and saw a lot of death i got used to
death at the age of 9 to 12.
is that the saddest [ __ ] thing that
was his childhood
because these banker [ __ ] and these oil
companies it's [ __ ]
ridiculous [ __ ] ridiculous it always
comes down to those two [ __ ]
energy and money it comes down to those
two [ __ ] [ __ ] no matter where it is
no matter where it is
um anyway one of our neighbor uh
that was an officer died during the war
they brought his
body in a truck wrapped up with a
blanket that was exactly like mine
at night i couldn't sleep and think
about him and death
i was taught to never question god but i
was questioning god that night to the
things that are happening yeah
that's a totally normal when you see
what human beings can do to other human
beings [ __ ] if you see what animals do
to some other animals
like why are there komodo dragons
you know i understand they got a kill to
eat why can't they just kill them they
start eating them before they're even
dead i mean it's just
[ __ ] ridiculous um it was the most
terrifying time of my life because i
thought god is going to kill me for
thinking this way
well welcome to organized religion but
obviously nothing happened i stopped
questioning god a religion till isis
came along
uh when ye
yazitis got attacked by
it says is i don't know if that's isis
or what in 2014
they got kicked out of their homes and
kid and kidnapped their girls
and women to be served as slaves to
members to is members
i went to sinjar mountain to help them
while they were coming down from the
mountain an old woman
run down to an officer jumped on his
feet kissing
and cow towing begging him to bring her
granddaughter back from is
that was the moment i lost my religion
and the idea of god
i couldn't live there anymore so i moved
to sweden
jesus christ this is a [ __ ] heavy
email my family doesn't know that i'm
not a religious person anymore if i did
tell them they would never talk to me
but it's fine for them not to know
that's the smartest thing to do
so my problem is that i've fallen in
love with the kurdish girl that is
religious
i did tell her that i'm not religious
because
she deserves to know she cried for two
days and then told me she's okay with it
i guess she's hoping that i'll change my
mind in the future
which i'm very sure that i won't every
time i remind her that i'm not religion
religious person she just ignores it
uh i always thought that love is a silly
thing that doesn't exist until i meet
her
it doesn't matter we are engaged now
we've talked about kids recently i told
her that i do not want kids to grow up
with any religious
ideas but she thinks there'll be
monsters if we did that
i'm okay with her being religious but
i'm definitely not okay with my kids
growing up on this idea
love is strong but not strong enough to
choose your life partner
uh we've been we've known each other for
over three years now
that's the end of the email yeah you
need to work that out before you marry
her
um but you know you're allowed to think
what
you think and she's allowed to think
what she thinks you know if she's
if it works for her it works for her and
but i definitely i
100 see when i see what people do to
other people
um yeah i just don't
like the capability
of [ __ ] evil is just i i don't get it
i don't get it
i think if there is a god that made us
he or she could have done a lot better
[ __ ] job
um all right fat people bragging dear
billy zigzag
i don't care who gets the vaccine before
me because i'm not
an at-risk person i do however think
it's [ __ ] crazy that fat people are
bragging about getting the vaccine first
on social media i keep seeing threads of
people
pictures of fat people throwing up peace
signs like they won
something these high-risk people were
the excuse to shut down businesses for a
year
and they're the first ones to be able to
go back and eat at a restaurant
and dude you should be a comedian this
is a killer bit
and somehow someone will think i'm a
dick for complaining
how about a tad bit of shame for not
taking care of yourself
yeah and slowing down the herd i i agree
i agree
you should turn that into your first
stand-up bit or just for the [ __ ] of it
sign up for an open mic and just do that
and get it off your chest
and it's even if you're bombed there'll
be one person laughing and then i'm
telling you it'll make your day
all right cruising for a bruising
dear billy the orange creamsicle
i know you're trying to trash me but i
kind of like that one they call him the
creamsicle kid
um i am a 22 year old rhys uh university
graduate from toronto
canada working on the weekend like usual
and i can i am currently working a job
landscaping to make money until i start
firefighter school this summer anyway
i have recently picked up a bad habit of
boozing very consistently since the
start of the pandemic yeah a lot of
people i think are drinking heavily
i'm bored and what can i say i like my
beer i am drinking anywhere between four
and eight beers every other night
and sometimes more often than not
uh i think every other night is more
often than not well no that's
50 50 right no i suck at math i drink
every night
oh and sometimes more often than not i
drink every night i know you've been
sober for a number of years now
sort of i was california sober as josh
adam myers says
and basically we then kind of took over
you know and i was having an edible like
four or five
times a [ __ ] you know
a week and then i was just like this is
i have a problem against and i had to
walk away from that
um so i've really just been sober since
february 28th
so he says i am thinking i should follow
in your footsteps or at least drop down
the number of days a week i'm drinking
i don't know about you but i use booze
to calm my anxiety
and spice up my days so i don't spiral
into a fit of depression
hey welcome to the club
um he goes however
as we all know too much booze can lead
to bad decisions that make you feel like
a piece of [ __ ] the next morning
and i absolutely hate that feeling i
have talked to a therapist before and it
didn't do a whole lot for me
anyway i am just looking for some tips
on how you got the booze out of your
life because i don't want my future to
go down the wrong path
thanks a lot i love the podcast all the
best you the lovely neon your wonderful
kids
cheers and go [ __ ] yourself um all right
well everybody's different
for me um i just was done with booze
and i had kids and i felt i had only a
daughter at that point i just didn't
feel good about being drunk downs
getting drunk downstairs while she was
sleeping upstairs
um yeah and then [ __ ] and then
whenever i would have like an edible
like
you know if i was high i would just like
she and i'd be like you know she's
sleeping nothing's gonna happen i can do
this and it's just stupid if something
does happen what the [ __ ]
we have earthquakes out here god knows
what could happen i'd be high as [ __ ]
it was stupid so um
the big thing that's making you do that
made me do it was
this underlying depression and sadness
from
all the [ __ ] that made me want to be you
know drove me into being a comedian and
i think at some point
you kind of have to work that out uh
maybe you had the wrong therapist maybe
you weren't ready for therapy but it's
always good to talk to somebody about it
you know talk to a therapist said i
tried therapy it hasn't worked
you know for me but you know i
i'm drinking too much and i think i'm
drinking because
to stay away from these depressive
thoughts and that's not the right reason
to drink
so um i would just suggest being really
open to either friends and family about
it
and try to get a new therapist if you
can
and just put it out there and tell
people that you're drinking too much and
you don't want to drink and you drink it
for the wrong reasons
and you want to stop and if you ask for
help people you'll be surprised people
will
really help you out and um
you know i'll tell you the great thing
about not boozing is the next morning
you feel great you don't have to
apologize to anybody and
you know everything you said was what
you meant
was you know was what you wanted to say
at least um
all right here we go last one here i am
a jealous girlfriend
um all right hey bill i'm a 25 year old
woman with some
abandonment daddy issues i know this is
who i am but not necessarily the person
i want to be so of course i'm in therapy
to work this stuff out well i got to
commend you for knowing all that about
yourself
at the young age of 25. you're way ahead
of the game
um unfortunately my boyfriend is still
sometimes subjected to my jealous nature
for example the other day he invited me
to come visit him at work
and when i showed up i met his new
co-worker who was very prissy pretty
uh i should mention that i myself am
beautiful but even if i wasn't i know my
boyfriend loves me to the end of the
earth and doesn't want to be with
anybody else
that being said i could still feel my
italian blood boil
when i met this girl i spent the rest of
the day
begging myself not to let my emotions
get the best of me and say
something to my boyfriend my
self-control lasted until the next
morning that's pretty good
when i finally brought it up a short
little spat ensued but about 15 minutes
later we were both hugging it and
apologizing
well this seems you know this don't beat
yourself up after this you know what
your problem is and you're working your
way through it
you're able to control it to the next
morning and then even when it finally
leaked out
15 minutes later you you know you were
apologizing
he apologized you know i don't know why
he apologized you [ __ ] started it but
you know if that's how it works usually
that's how the math is done that's great
though
so anyways he said i told him that i
understood he has no control over how
attractive his coworkers are
i also know that it's normal to flirt a
little bit outside of a relationship i
myself
innocently flirt with others from time
to time so i'm being super
hypocritical by getting all butt hurt at
the thought of him doing it
i also acknowledge that every time i get
jealous like this
it probably makes him feel more and more
suffocated which will probably hurt our
relationship in the long term
uh he handled this interaction like a
champ forgave me for getting jealous
said it was no big deal and made a joke
about me being on my period
you guys sound like he got a cool
relationship to me
um i know he's being genuine when he
says it's okay but i can't help
but put myself in his shoes i which is
so hey that's something that's really
difficult for people to do that's called
empathy
it's a tough thing for most human beings
to do putting themselves in somebody
else's shoes
uh if i had a partner who acted the way
i did i would probably lose a little
respect for them
with every incident and know i would
start feeling resentful and suffocated
my question is do you have any advice
about damage control is there anything i
can do to get a little
self-respect respect back and relieve
any guilt he might have about
being attracted to other people
furthermore do you have any advice on
how i can calm the [ __ ] down whenever i
start overthinking and getting jealous
thanks for your insightful comedy p.s go
leafs
oh another person from toronto working
on the weekend like you joe
um
i think a lot of this is in your own
head
i think if you you had a little hissy
fit and then 15 minutes you apologized
and you you're owning up to your
behavior
i don't think i think that he knows that
this is something that you're working on
so as long as you own up to it i don't
think he loses respect for you i mean
i'm sitting there thinking like all the
stuff i was reading about you
i was thinking this woman's a keeper you
know nobody's perfect
and you actually are looking at yourself
you're examining yourself you're in
therapy
you [ __ ] up you apologize you feel bad
you put yourself in the other person's
shoes you can't ask any more of that
from a person
so just keep working on yourself and i
would actually not be so hard on
yourself
unless you don't apologize which you did
and if it's over 15 minutes later then
you know
i don't know my wife flipped out and
then 15 minutes later apologizes to me
it's [ __ ] over it's squashed it's
like when you fight
and then you're silent for the whole
[ __ ] day and then you get a
half-assed apology
and then they do it 10 minutes later
again that's when resentment comes in so
i think
i think you're in the clear here you're
fine keep working on yourself
you're way ahead of the game you're only
25 years old you're a kid
so uh you're gonna be fine that that's
what i say
all right okay all right everybody
that's the podcast
um i don't want to tell you i'm just
looking around my [ __ ] nice clean
office and i'm loving life right now i
hope you guys are enjoying your life
all right owning up to what the [ __ ]
you're doing having empathy for other
people
not working for banks or oil companies
helping out people less fortunate let's
try to be better people man
um all right go [ __ ] yourselves and i'll
talk to you
i'll check in on you on thursday